قد لا تتجلى في ملعب امازونيا الصوره
التقليديه المعروفه عن ملاعب البرازيل
ولكن المؤكده انه سيجت هذب اعدادا غفيره
من المشجعين لانه يقع في قلب اكبر منطقه
غابات في العالم والجدل يبدو مستمرا حول
الاسباب التي دفعت المسؤولين لاختيار
مانوس لاحتضان بعض مباريات البطوله نسبه
الرطوبه في عاصمه اكبر محميه غابات مطيره
في العالم لا تقل عن 80% فبالنسبه الى
مدرب المنتخب الانجليزي سيكون الامر شبيها
بالعذاب مع درجه حراره قد تلامس الخ زد
على ذلك العنف مما دع الصحافه البريطانيه
ربما بكثير من الخبث الى اطلاق صفه جهنم
مدينه الموت
عليها لكن الاكثر اثاره للقلق هو كيفيه
الوصول اليها
فالوسيط ولا تقل الرحله عن اربع ساعات لا
تقل تكلفتها ايضا عن 600 دولار والمطار
نفسه مازال تحت الانجاز ولم تكتمل اشغاله
لكن هناك ايضا مزايا فما يحدها من جميع
جهاتها هو الاحراش وتجمعات السكان
الاصليين وتحرس قبائل ديسان توكانا على
الترحيب بالضيوف بمصنع تهم التقليديه
والرقص ويقول زعيم قبلي انهم استفادوا من
كاس العالم حيث ان اعداد السياح لا تقارن
بالماضي لكنه يشدد على ان السياح لن
يحصلوا على كل ما يرغبون فيه لان الكاس
ستكون من نصيب
البرازيل